GOVERNOR'S SEAT.
IS "SPECIAL REPORT" ."
GOOD EVENING.
I'M BRET BAIER.
COMING TO YOU TONIGHT FROM
LOS ANGELES.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THE DYNAMIC
POLITICS HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
SPEAK WITH THE TOP REPUBLICAN IN
THE GOVERNOR'S RACE SO FAR IN
JUST A FEW MINUTES.
FIRST NIGHT, PRESIDENT TRUMP
GOING AFTER THE RUSSIA COLLUSION
INVESTIGATION AGAIN.
HE SAYS THE FBI HAS BEEN CAUGHT
IN A MAJOR SCANDAL, POTENTIALLY
ONE OF THE BIGGEST POLITICAL
UPROAR'S IN HISTORY, ACCORDING
TO THE PRESIDENT.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT JOHN ROBERTS
STARTS US OFF THIS EVENING FROM
THE NORTH LAWN.
>> GOOD EVENING.
CRITICS SAYING PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS OVERSTATING THE CASE WHEN HE
CLAIMS THAT HIS CAMPAIGN MAY
HAVE BEEN SPIED ON.
BUT THAT'S NOT EVEN SLOWING THE
PRESIDENT WHO IS ON A FAST BOIL
ABOUT WHAT HE SAYS COULD BE A
HUGE POLITICAL SCANDAL.
LEAVING THE WHITE HOUSE TODAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP LET FLY ON WHAT
HE IS NOW CALLING SPYGATE TO.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE A VERY SERIOUS
EVENT BUT WE WILL FIND OUT.
WHEN THEY LOOK AT THE DOCUMENTS,
I THINK PEOPLE ARE GOING TO SEE
A LOT OF BAD THINGS HAPPENED.
I HOPE IT'S NOT SO.
BECAUSE IF IT IS, THERE'S NEVER
BEEN ANYTHING LIKE IT IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP CLAIMS THE
CAMPAIGN AFTER A CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMANT HAD CONTACT AND
MEETINGS WITH THREE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN OFFICIALS.
CARTER PAGE, GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS, AND SAM CLOVIS.
IN A MEETING MONDAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOLD DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN
AND FBI DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER
WRAY TO WORK OUT HOW THEY COULD
GET DOCUMENTS RELATING TO THE
INFORMANT AND THEY FACE OUR
REQUEST TO SURVEIL PAGE TWO
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATORS.
>> WE COLLECT SPYGATE.
YOU ARE CALLING IT SPYGATE.
A LOT OF BAD THINGS HAVE
HAPPENED.
I WANT A LOT TO GET TOGETHER.
THEY WILL SIT IN THE ROOM.
HOPEFULLY THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
WORK IT OUT AMONG THEMSELVES.
>> AT THE MEETING TOMORROW,
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN DEVIN NUNES, GOVERNMENT
OVERSIGHT CHAIRMAN TREY GOWDY,
ED O'CALLAGHAN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, FBI
DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER WRAY AND
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE, DAN COATS.
NO DEMOCRATS INVITED.
SENATE MINORITY LEADER TODAY
INSISTED CONGRESSMAN NUNES IS
TRYING TO INTERFERE WITH THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION AND PUT
THE BLAME FOR THAT SQUARELY ON
PAUL RYAN'S SHOULDERS.
>> SPEAKER RYAN IS ALLOWING THIS
TO HAPPEN, WHO WILL FOREVER BE
-- IT WILL FOREVER BE A BLOT ON
HIS RECORD.
HE CAN'T BE SO AFRAID OF THE
HARD RIGHT AND THE PRESIDENT
THAT HE WOULD ALLOW THIS KIND OF
BANANA REPUBLIC BEHAVIOR TO GO
FORWARD.
>> CONGRESSMAN GOWDY TODAY SAID
IT'S OKAY WITH HIM IF DEMOCRATS
ATTEND.
>> I DON'T CARE WHO COMES.
I AM NOT IN CONTROL OF THE
INVITE LIST.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO SHOW UP, SHOW
UP WITH AN OPEN MIND AND CLOSED
LIPS.
IN OTHER WORDS, DON'T LEAK LIKE
A SIEVE.
>> THE ACCUSATIONS OF SPYGATE
EXPLODED AS PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
ON HIS WAY TO LONG ISLAND FOR A
LAW ENFORCEMENT ROUNDTABLE ON
THE MURDEROUS GANG MS-13.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN A LATHER
ABOUT DEMOCRATS' CRITICISM OF A
USE OF THE WORD ANIMALS.
>> DEMOCRATS, NANCY PELOSI IS AN
EXAMPLE, ARE TRYING TO DEFEND
MS-13 GANG MEMBERS.
I CALLED THEM ANIMALS.
AND I WAS MET WITH REBUKE.
THEY SAID THEY ARE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE NOT PEOPLE.
THESE ARE ANIMALS.
>> AS NORTH KOREA TOOK
JOURNALISTS ON A TOUR OF THE
NUCLEAR TEST SITE IT SAYS IT'S
CLOSING DOWN, PRESIDENT TRUMP
AGAIN SUGGESTED THE DAY FOR A
SUMMIT MIGHT SLIDE.
>> SOMEDAY A DATE WILL
ABSOLUTELY HAPPEN.
IT COULD VERY WELL BE JUNE 12.
WE WILL SEE.
WE WILL KNOW NEXT WEEK.
>> TODAY PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO
WEIGHED IN ON THE NFL OWNERS
DECISION TO REQUIRE PLAYERS ON
THE SIDELINES TO STAND FOR THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM.
THE PRESIDENT TELLING OUR
BRIAN KILMEADE IN AN INTERVIEW
TO AIR ON "FOX & FRIENDS"
TOMORROW THAT HE IS HAPPY WITH
THE NFL'S DECISION BUT NOT
PARTICULARLY HAPPY ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THE OWNERS WILL GIVE
THE OPPORTUNITY OR OPTION OF
WRITING OUT THE NATIONAL ANTHEM
IN THE LOCKER ROOM.
BRET.
>> Bret: STORY ON THAT A
LITTLE BIT LATER.
JOHN, THERE IS SOME REPORTING
TONIGHT THAT THE WHITE HOUSE IS
CONSIDERING OPENING UP THE
MEETING TO POSSIBLY DEMOCRATS AS
WELL.
CLASSIFIED INTELLIGENCE BRIEFING
CLASSIFIED INTELLIGENCE BRIEFIN
BRIEFING.
MAY BE PUSHING IT DOWN FROM
THURSDAY.
>> CHUCK SCHUMER HAS BEEN
STATING IN THE LAST 24 HOURS
THAT HE THINKS THEY SHOULD BE
HANDLED BY THE SO-CALLED GANG OF
EIGHT LEADERSHIP IN CONGRESS.
THERE HAD NOT BEEN ANY MOVE
TOWARD THAT BUT IF THIS REPORT
IS CORRECT, THERE COULD BE SOME
MOVE.
THAT WOULD BE IN ADDITION TO
CHAIRMAN NUNES AND GERMAN GAUDI
PAIR WILL RUN SOME TRAPS ON IT